Ontario Brown is always in a rush
when she's not teaching the 40 kids who
attend her daycare center she's cleaning
or answering the phone all right bye
love you bye or trying to pay bills to
keep the center open the overhead is
expensive like Insurance the car
insurance
um the liability insurance by the
accident paper Brown opened kids with
goals Unlimited in Hopewell Virginia
just before the pandemic the timing was
terrible but she resisted closing even
as enrollment dropped loans and personal
credit cards kept things going but with
no profit coming in brown was forced to
work a second job as a nurse working
overnight hours I leave here at 5 PM go
hold up my kids off my husband take a
shower go to my nighttime job that's a
30 hour work day I try to go in my car
to take a power nap come back in
I am dead to Earth Brown says she was
relieved when rescue money came from
Congress
I don't know I first got the check I was
so happy because those payments will end
September 30th and experts warrant an
estimated 70 000 daycares will close
parents will leave the labor force and
the U.S economy could contract by an
estimated 10 billion dollars if Congress
or the Biden Administration doesn't act
3.2 million children could lose their
child care we think that people are
going to have to pay high prices that
they won't be able to afford that
providers are going to have to shut
their doors Hopewell Virginia is within
a child care desert where there is
simply not enough care for all the
children who need it families will
travel long distances from the
surrounding four counties to bring their
children to this Center and there is a
list of more than 70 families waiting
for a spot to open Brown says she'll
have to raise tuition to make up for the
Lost Government funding the extra keeps
my staff at 18 15 an hour if that
increases I'm not going to be able to
meet their
pay how much do you take home in your
salary from here
I pay myself with a thousand dollars a
month
laughs
if I do that sometimes like this month I
got zero it doesn't take a teacher to
conclude the numbers don't add up the
children need to be cared for so I see
in my and use it and Brown says it makes
her happy to do it with the Peabody
don't like the one because
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Hopewell
Virginia
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera